[Musique]
bonjour à tous est ravie de vous
retrouver sur public sénat hier le
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
était auditionné par la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat le ministre a
répondu aux questions des sénateurs sur
deux projets de lois qui portent d'abord
sur la reprise de la dette sociale mais
aussi sur la création d'une cinquième
branche de la sécurité sociale dédiée à
la prise en charge du handicap et du
grand âge je vous propose d'écouter ces
échanges et on se retrouve après ce soir
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé sur les
projets de loi organique et ordinaire
relatifs monsieur ministre à la dette
sociale et à l'autonomie que notre
commission examinera donc demain avant
le passage en séance publique à partir
du 1er juillet prochain sur le
rapporteur cette audition monsieur
ministre est ouverte à la presse elle a
lieu en présentiel et en visioconférence
ont combiné 2 7 fois et je salue donc
nos collègues qui participe en salle et
qui participe à distance cette audition
est également monsieur ministres
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du sénat
ces deux projets doit donc qui nous sont
soumis vise donc à transférer un montant
significatif de la dette sociale 136
milliards d'euros à la caisse
d'amortissement de la dette sociale la
cades est ce dont la durée de vie se
trouve donc prolonger d'autant monsieur
le ministre votre collègue ministre de
l'action et des comptes publics
gérald darmanin dont le nom figure
également sur ses projets doigt m'a fait
savoir pas directement mais par la voix
de son cabinet que sa présence n'était
pas nécessaire puisque vous étiez chargé
par le gouvernement de répondre à
l'ensemble des questions que pourrait
poser la commission des affaires
sociales j'en ai pris bonne note
j'ai été un peu surpris quand même que
le ministre des comptes publics ne
soient pas présents pour la présentation
d'un texte relatif à la dette sociale
mais ce texte ne manque pas de toutes
façons de surprendre à plusieurs égards
on peut ainsi s'étonner que le
gouvernement choisisse de présenter les
conséquences du prolongement de la durée
de vie de la cades est ce dans un projet
de loi ordinaire dans les conséquences
devant être tirées par la prochaine loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
plutôt que de présenter directement un
projet de loi de financement
rectificative
vous ne manquerez pas de nous objecter
que comme vous l'avez déjà fait ainsi
d'ailleurs que monsieur darmana qu'un
tel texte est prématurée car la
situation financière de sécurité sociale
n'est pas stabilisée et que faudrait
vous citez monsieur ministre en
présenter un toutes les semaines bien
que nous nous préparions à examiner le
troisième mois le troisième pardon
projet de loi de finances rectificative
je ne peux que saluer le perfectionnisme
les scrupules et le souci du détail du
gouvernement mais comment comprendre
alors et c'est mon deuxième sujet
d'étonnement sur ce texte
l'adjonction au dernier moment d'un
volet consacré à l'autonomie dont nous
ne savons absolument rien rien dans ce
texte sur le financement sur la
gouvernance sur les prestations servies
ou encore sur les bénéficiaires
une seule chose semble claire il s'agira
d'une cinquième branche de la sécurité
sociale
le symbole est fort mais le contenu
d'autant plus décevant pour financer
cette nouvelle branche de la sécurité
sociale le texte opère une dérivation de
recettes de la cades est ce qui reçoit
ainsi un montant sans précédent de
dettes mais moins de recettes pour les
amortir
autre sujet d'étonnement
2,6 yves au danaïdes en passant par
prométhée les références mythologiques
ne manquent pas pour évoquer la cad s
mais une des personnes auditionnées par
notre commission a préféré plus
modestement se référer aux facéties du
sapeur camember pour qualifier cette
opération de recettes après ce rapport
d'étonnement monsieur le ministre je
vous laisse bien volontiers la parole
pour présenter ces deux projets de loi
avant que je la donne au rapporteur
général qui en est rapporteur et au
président un mec ce puits aux collègues
qui souhaite vous interroger en
commençant par le rapporteur aux
personnes âgées monsieur bernard bonne
et ensuite tous ceux qui voudraient bien
ça se fait monsieur véran vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
madame mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je vous remercie pour votre invitation
je sais que votre commission est très
sensible aux questions de finances
sociales c'est bien volontiers que je me
présente devant vous afin de répondre à
vos questions en amont de l'examen du
texte vous l'avais dit à partir du 1er
juillet prochain en séance et dès demain
mercredi en commission des affaires
sociales une nouvelle reprise de dette
par la cades est ce c'est une nécessité
de court terme au regard de la situation
que nous traversons qui nous inquiète
tous c'est aussi un outil qui nous
permet de regarder en face les grands
défis de notre temps le temps court et
le temps long ce sont les deux aspects
de ce projet doit le temps court du fait
des circonstances et le temps long de
l'ambition il ya quelques mois le retour
à l'équilibré des comptes sociaux était
proche et nous étions sur le point de
fermer la cad s après 28 années
d'existence pour apurer la dette passée
j'étais alors rapporteur général du
budget de la sécurité sociale à
l'assemblée nationale et nous nous
félicitions avec jean marie
vanlerenberghe mon homologue de l'époque
au sénat des perspectives plus enjoué
que jamais vous avez parlé du rocher de
sisyphe
du tombeau des danaïdes c'est vrai que
la métaphore n'est pas fausse
et l'année que nous venons de traverser
la teste la crise sanitaire rebat
désormais des cartes on assiste à la
reconstitution au moins temporaire de
déficits importants autant que vous je
le regrette néanmoins il est
indispensable d'assurer le financement
de la sécurité sociale
je ne vous apprends rien la trésorerie
de la sécurité sociale est géré par
l'acoss
avec une contrainte sur la maturité des
emprunts qui ne peuvent excéder 12 mois
cette trésorerie grévé par 30 milliards
d'euros de déficits passés cumulé à fin
2010 9 a été soumise à de très fortes
tensions du fait des mesures prises et
mises en oeuvre pendant la crise même
dans la perspective d'un rebond de
l'économie que nous attendons tous les
déficits à venir sont inéluctables par
conséquent seul un transfert important
peut permettre à la kadey ce déplacement
à horizon long qui sont les plus
sécurisants et celle cette reprise nous
protégera contre le risque de devoir
décaler un jour le paiement des
prestations sociales par manque de
financement en situation que ni vous ni
moi ne souhaitons bien évidemment ne
perdons pas de vue que l'hôpital public
dont chacun connaît les contraintes
notamment financières trouverait dans
cette reprise de dettes de l'air et de
la visibilité
ce que l'on propose avec ce projet de
loi c'est donc une opération de bonne
gestion de la sécu qui renouvelle
l'engagement de rembourser les dettes de
la sécurité sociale dont une partie
découle de la crise actuelle c'est
respecter les principes de 1996 selon
lesquelles la dette sociale est gérée
vertueusement et apurer au principal
concrètement ça veut dire que nous
devons prolonger la durée pendant
laquelle nous mobilisons des recettes
c'est un dsg frr pour rembourser cette
dette pour neuf années supplémentaires
de 2024 à 2033
voilà pour le premier aspect du texte
mais à l'occasion de cet engagement nous
posons aussi la première pierre d'une
réforme très attendue celle de la perte
d'autonomie comme en 1945 il a été
décidé de créer une assurance sociale
publique contre le risque de maladie ou
d'accident du travail
à cette époque aujourd'hui nous faisons
le choix d'une nouvelle assurance
publique contre ce qui est devenu un
nouveau risque auquel un certain nombre
de français peuvent faire face
aujourd'hui ou demain et ils seront plus
nombreux à y faire face demain puisque
les chiffres sont sans appel en 2040
près de 15 % des français se soit près
de 11 millions de personnes auront plus
de 75 ans c'est deux fois plus
qu'aujourd'hui
un travail important a été débuté à
l'assemblée nationale autour de la
création d'une cinquième branche de la
sécurité sociale
nous aurons certainement l'occasion d'en
débattre j'imagine en tout cas dans
quelques instants
je vois que oui la question du
traitement spécifique de la dette liée
aux copies de 19
reste une vraie question dont les
économistes débattent à juste titre et
pour laquelle les champs approprié et
globalement l'échelon européen mais il
faut agir vite
r ce stade la solution défendue dans ce
projet de loi me semble être la
meilleure voire la seule qui soit je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur ministre je
passe donc la parole jean marie
vanlerenberghe qui à quelques questions
quelques coupures yale j'ai quelques
questions monsieur le ministre mais ça
ne vous étonnera pas puisque vous avez
déjà d'anticiper certaines alors j'en ai
six jeux je pense que il y en aura
d'autres de la part de nos collègues
la première porte je ne reviens pas
évidemment sur la description que vous
avez fait deux
la loi organique et de la loi ordinaire
la première porte sur le transfert à la
cades est de 92 milliards au titre des
déficits de l'exercice des exercices
2020 et de 1 2023 et au vu des dernières
hypothèses dont vous disposez est ce que
vous pourriez nous livrer le le boom où
nous nous dire plus précisément si le
calibrage et correcte
aujourd'hui est-ce que la trajectoire
des comptes sociaux est aujourd'hui
précise est ce que pour la deuxième
question
selon le gouvernement la dette sociale
créée par la crise actuelle devrait être
isolé et avoir un statut particulier
incidemment le gouvernement a abandonné
la doctrine du chacun chez soi qui était
celle que votre collègue qui n'est pas
présent aujourd'hui responsable
responsable des comptes publics nous
avait expliqué il n'y a pas si longtemps
et l'ensemble des mesures de baisse de
recettes de la sécurité sociale qui
pourrait intervenir dans le cadre du
plan de relance lui seront elles bien
qu'on pense et moi c'est un point
important c'est que quand nous étions
vous étiez rapporteur général
nous avions eu des discussions sur ce
point nous nous étions pas loin d'être
d'accord pourquoi
troisième question est ce que la cades
est ce qui doit prendre à sa charge le
financement de l'amortissement d'un
tiers de la dette des abysses mon sens
sans de santé dette hospitalière
pourquoi la transférer à la cades est ce
selon d'ailleurs un mécanisme un peu
compliqué je dois dire cette importante
dérogation mission de la cades est ce
parce que la dette hospitalière est une
dette principalement aux immobilière la
dette des hôpitaux porté par l'état
c'est l'état qui est propriétaire des
hôpitaux jusqu'aux jusqu'à nouvel ordre
et donc hors du champ de la sécurité
sociale est ce que ça ne constitue pas
un dangereux précédent points 4 le
projet de loi prévoit qu'à compter de
2024 un quart de la csg affectées à la
cades est ce sera dérivé pour financer
des dépenses courantes relatives à la
dépendance
une telle opération ne va-t-elle pas le
message que la dette sociale et éternel
tout comme la dette de l'état et sera
transmise aux générations futures
le cas échéant pourquoi continuer à
rembourser le capital et ne pas dégager
des moyens supplémentaires pour les
dépenses courantes
j'ai un peu provocant et je dois dire
à quoi d'ailleurs cinquième point servir
à la fraction de la csg affecté à la cns
a pour financer la perte d'autonomie qui
représente la modique somme de 2
milliards 3 commence sera t-elle
répartis dans les différentes sections
de son budget les dernières questions
pouvez vous nous donner davantage de
précisions sur la méthode retenue pour
ouvrir le chantier du cinquième risque
par exemple sur le calendrier des
travaux
les orientations proposées risque ou
branches où va votre préférence
d'ailleurs celui nice ou encore nous
dira qui serait confié le rapport de
préfiguration attendus pour la
mi-septembre
je rappelle que pour certains nos
collègues qui n'étaient peut-être pas
tout à fait aux faits là le texte
initial du projet de loi prévoit y ait
la création à cinquième risque et c'est
l'assemblée nationale qui a précisé et
qui a demandé que ça soit 5 une
cinquième branche
voilà monsieur ministre qu'elles sont
une première question je vous laisse
répondre à ses premières questions il y
en aura de la suite mais monsieur le
rapporteur général le statut de la dette
que vides
c'est une bonne question et c'est une
importante question merci de le voir
poser est ce que est ce que c'est une
date qui relève de l'état
est ce que c'est une rolls date qui
relève de la sécu est ce que c'est une
dette hybride dont on pourrait discuter
du statut en inclinaison naturelle
aurait été vers la troisième possibilité
à savoir la discussion d'un statut
spécial à part pour cette lettre coville
considérant c'est un effort qui pourrait
être partagé et qui pourraient
bénéficier pourquoi pas d'un
amortissement particulier mais même en
introspection a été vite balayés par
l'urgence je lui ai dit 'si nous opérons
les capacités de la kos a emprunté
suffisamment sur les marchés à court
terme pour pouvoir délivrer les
prestations sociales n'aura eu un débat
très important philosophique sur le
statut d'une dette et son remboursement
on ne pourrait plus verser les
prestations sociales donc il a fallu
décider vite
dès lors il ya un vecteur connu que déjà
été utilisée par dans le temps en 2011
pour la dernière fois qui est un
transfert à la kadey ce qu'est la nature
est d'emprunter sur du long terme
après quand on rentre dans le détail la
dette qu'ovide à proprement parler sa
composante principale plus de 30
milliards d'euros
c'est certes une décision de l'état
m'enfin ça reste une réduction ou une
suppression de cotisation à travers le
chômage partiel on peut considérer que
la sécurité sociale a ainsi joué son
rôle d'amortisseur social de
préservation des emplois et de la lutte
contre la pauvreté
c'est vrai que la chaîne de décision n'a
pas émaner des partenaires sociaux dans
le cas de la gestion de la sécu enfin je
pense que considérer que le chômage
partiel sont une mesure de protection
sociale ne fait pas en tout cas ne
mérite pas les cheveux sur la tête
l'autre partie la dette qu'ovide c'est
une augmentation de l'ondam lie à des
dépenses
vous les connaissez matériel de
protection masques et est prise en
charge de soins hospitaliers médicaments
qui relève parfaitement la sécurité
sociale donc on a les jeux encore débat
philosophique important parfois avec mon
homologue du m&a cp puisque je suis
sensée le représenter aujourd'hui dans
cette dans cette intervention
je ne m'exprimerai pas pour autant à sa
place sur la question des noms
compensation mais encore une fois la
sécu a joué son rôle d'amortisseur
social sur la compensation stade de bas
un débat qui relève traditionnellement
du plfss
mais je note que en même temps qu'on
discute de cela l'état s'apprête à faire
un geste conséquent à destination de
l'ondam dans le cas du cigl la santé et
je ne crois pas que nous soyons en clin
de vendresse que la sécu rembourse à
l'état les sommes qui seront alloués on
a de la suite dans les idées
merci aussi
sur la question de la dette hospitalière
et la reprise de dette qui serait porté
par la cades est ce moi je vais vous
dire le fond de ma pensée sexy une dette
hospitalière
certes c'est beaucoup pour du bâti enfin
c'est la conséquence d'un ondam hyper
serré pendant des années et donc c'est
l'objet c'est la conséquence de la
maîtrise médicalisée et donc c'est
clairement en lien avec les règles de
bonne gestion qui se sont appliqués dans
le champ de la sécurité sociale la dette
hospitalière n'est que le reflet de la
maîtrise médicalisée donc que cette
dette hospitalière soit reprise dans le
champ de la protection sociale à travers
la cad s ne me pose pas la moindre
la moindre difficulté je trouve même
plutôt cohérent avait posé la question
sur la trajectoire des comptes sociaux
on est sur un calibrage 52 milliards
d'ici à 2020 c'est l'hypothèse du plfr 3
vous le savez nous n'avons pas encore pu
tirer toutes les conclusions des
dépenses et des pertes de recettes liées
à la crise est encore à l'heure à
laquelle je vous parle du chômage
partiel de pays et encore des dépenses
sanitaires liés à l'épidémie
donc je ne peux pas vous dire
précisément à leurs prêts même au
milliard près pour être tout à fait
franc quel sera l'état global dette
sociale liée à la cades est allié à la
koko vide lorsque nous en aurons pour de
bon terminé et c'est pour ça que nous
avons été prudents et que nous avons
débloqué de manière prospective et
prévisionnel des dépenses
supplémentaires à venir que nous mettons
d'emblée à la cades est suivant ainsi un
mécanisme qui a été défloré si vous me
permettez l'expression en 2011 par une
autre majorité qui avait alors déjà
anticipé sur une pluralité de 4 ans ou
de cinq ans me semble-t-il des dettes
des déficits à venir de leurs deux plus
importants à l'époque je veux pas dire
de bêtises de 59 milliards d'euros me
semble-t-il
donc on n'est pas dans un mécanisme
inconnu ni dans une terre dans une terre
vierge pose ensuite des questions sur le
transfert csg cns a d'abord remarquer qu
on ne change pas les règles de
remboursement de la dette sociale en
cours de route nous ont fait le choix
d'attendre 2024 avant de procéder à ce
jeu de tuyauterie justement vis-à-vis de
nos créanciers pour leur montrer que
nous respectons les règles de
remboursement que nous étions fixés sans
quoi nous aurions pu considérer que dès
2021 et sans plus attendre nous aurions
pu transférer de 3 milliards d'euros à
la scène et cela
engagé sans plus attendre des dépenses
nécessaires dans le champ de la perte
d'autonomie est considéré qu'on aurait
pu repousser de six mois ou un an il
beaucoup d'amendements l'assemblée
nationale sur ce sujet mais le choix que
nous avons fait c'est de respecter les
engagements que nous avions pris ensuite
lorsque j'ai présenté au premier
ministre qui l'a acceptée ce mécanisme
de transfert d'une partie de la csg
affectées à la cades est vers la scène
et ça j'ai utilisé une métaphore qui est
une métaphore que les français pour un
certain nombre connaissent en tout cas
j'ai eu dont j'ai eu à connaître il ya
quelques années qui est la rediscussion
d'un prêt avec sa banque
on revoit le tableau d'amortissement de
son prêt on voit son banquier on lui dit
qu'on a une dépense importante à faire
comme l'achat d'une voiture qu'on a
besoin de dégager un peu de mensualités
on prolonge la durée de remboursement du
prêt ça diminue les mensualités au
prorata et en plus dans la manip parfois
on arrive à dire rediscuter le taux si
le taux est plus intéressant de sorte
que le prêt nous coûte moins cher
s'appelle mécanisme auquel nous nous
adonnons mais qui donc lille n'a rien de
de sacrilège par contre encore une fois
respecté en direct nous avions pris
jusqu'à 2024
l'utilisation ses 2,3 milliards d'euros
monsieur le sénateur vous connaissez la
réponse
vous savez que les prévisions les
perspectives qui sont en rapport olibeau
sur les dépenses liées à la perte
d'autonomie d'ici à 2030 sont
vertigineuses en termes de contenu en
terme de dépenses publiques on parle de
7 milliards on parle de 8 milliards
parce que la population vieillit parce
que l'augmentation de la perte
d'autonomie est inéluctable parce qu'il
ya des dépenses de rénovation de
construction d pad parce qu'il ya des
dépenses pour maintenir les personnes le
plus longtemps possible domicile parce
qu'il a des dépenses liées à
l'attractivité des métiers dans le grand
âge et dans l'autonomie est donc la
façon de dépenser nous le nous ne savons
que trop en revanche et 2,3 millions ne
sont pas pour seul de tout ces 2,3
milliards ne sont pas pour solde de tout
compte
il faudra évidemment identifier des
pistes de financement complémentaire
même en 2024 ce que nous savons aussi
c'est que d'ici à 2024 nous ne pouvons
pas attendre et qu'il faut engager des
dépenses importantes avec une politique
de l'offre notamment qui doit être
conduite dans le domaine de la perte
d'autonomie
c'est pourquoi je me suis engagé à
l'assemblée nationale à ce qu'il y ait
dans le prochain plfss au moins
d'euros mis sur la table pour pour je
dirais je veux dire enrichir non
certainement pas enrichir mais pour
venir conforter les dépenses de biais de
la perte d'autonomie dans le champ de la
cns à un milliard d'euros c'est plus que
les sommes qu'ils avaient été consacrés
à l'époque de la loi de michèle delaunay
qui avaient dit qu'ils avaient pu
obtenir 700 millions d'euros par an on
est déjà plus d'un milliard d'euros
supplémentaires à partir de l'année
prochaine c'est donc important mais ça
ne suffira pas et il faudra identifier
d'autres sources de financement et c'est
pourquoi pour répondre à votre dernière
question une mission a été décidé une
conférence des financeurs sur la
question de l'identification des moyens
financiers pour enrichir la scène et sa
fin plutôt par enrichir c'est une ville
et d'expression mais pour abonder la cns
a et une mission également de
préfiguration du cinquième risque ou la
5ème branche comme en a décidé
l'assemblée nationale en première
lecture cette mission je peux vous le
dire alors elle n'est pas encore
officiel j'espère que je ferai pas taper
sur les doigts mais c'est pas très grave
un inspecteur général des finances qui
connaît bien la scène et ça pour y avoir
siégé qui s'appelle monsieur vacher et
qui devrait commencer sa mission sous
peu merci bien monsieur card ou à la
parole oui merci président je pas
proprement parler de questions pense que
le rapporteur général l'a bien campé la
situation et a bien posé ces questions
parce que je constate monsieur mini
simplement c'est que je voudrais faire
un petit rappel tir rappel en arrière au
mois de novembre l'année dernière quand
nous avions eu la chance d'avoir
monsieur darmanin en audition et ils
nous avaient dit pas de problème
la croissance va absorber le stock de
dette qui est encore au passif de
l'acoss il faut se rappeler que les
projections de l'époque il était autour
de 30 40 milliards et que nous avions
fait des approches financières qui
montrait qu à l'extinction de la cades s
on serait paraît pratiquement entre 40
et 50 milliards encore de stocks de
dettes à l'acoss des gars qui m'avait un
peu surpris c'est que connaissant ces
chiffres là vous aviez déjà annoncés
alors vous étiez rapporteur de la
commission des affaires sociales à
l'assemblée nationale que dès 2024
on utilisera volant de marche que
donnera le rds pour financer l'autonomie
ou l'indépendance
j'avoue j'avais été surpris de cette
déclaration mais simplement je voudrais
rappeler ce contexte où là on est en
pleine incertitude et mon idée
personnelle était que le texte
incontournable que vous nous présentez
pour transférer à la cades est ce le
stock de dettes core à l'acoss avec les
conséquences déjà des déficits non
transférés avant et maintenant de la
crise du coc vide est incontournable
mais pourquoi pourquoi profité de ce
texte pour utiliser la cades est ce qu
une espèce de fourre tout où on
transfère 13 milliards de dettes des
hôpitaux pourquoi
quel intérêt de transférer à la cades
est bon vous dites que c'est justifié
parce que c'est un lien avec la sécurité
sociale
on pensait que la cades s ne financer
que des dépenses de fonctionnement là on
est dans dépenses immobilières et
d'investissements non est-ce que c'est
pas plutôt une façon habile de mettre
pardonnez moi l'expression un peu de
poussière sous le tapis pour vous
permettre d'aborder le ségur pour lequel
vous êtes en négociation donc dans de
meilleures conditions
on ne peut pas ne pas envisager cette
chose-là deuxièmement pourquoi
transférer cette dette à la cades est ce
alors qu'on sait parfaitement que
même si c'est pas très net on a eu une
audition de l' agence france trésor et
puis le président de la cad est tout à
l'heure mais manifestement c'est logique
parce que c'est l'état qui garantit les
dettes de la cad s manifestement l'état
emprunte dans de meilleures conditions
que ne peut le faire la cadette alors
évidemment on dirait on amortit le
capital mais je ne vois pas pourquoi ne
pas profiter du meilleur et meilleure
capacité d'emprunt ou rond point de vue
des taux lolita et transférés à la cades
s et puis pourquoi aussi à l'occasion de
ce texte lancé ce qui est tout à fait
vertueux parce que tout le monde est
tout à fait conscient que le problème de
la l'autonomie futur des personnes âgées
et il sera traité très vite on en parle
depuis des années mais pourquoi profiter
d'un texte purement financier qui se
rapporte à la cades s au transfert de la
dette sociale pour afficher un
financement à trois ans alors que le
besoin est urgent et tente on sait que
même à trois ans on se représentera à
peu près de deux milliards et demi
d'euros
il sera nettement insuffisant vous y
avez vous même fait référence puisque
vous avez lancé de la fourchette de 8 à
10 milliards de nécessaire donc voilà
voilà les questions qu'on se pose donc
je pense qu'il aurait été préférable
d'aborder cette organique à cet
ordinaire sur un approche purement
financière d'amortissement de la dette
sociale reporter traité d'une manière
différente
la dette des hôpitaux et puis reportée
on prochain plfss une approche de fonds
à la fois de fond sur comment moi je
parle pas de 2 5e branche je parle de
cinquième risque
comment créer ce cinquième risque
n'était pas plus intelligent de
dispatcher ce risque au sein des autres
branches de la sécurité sociale dont
c'est la vocation donc plutôt que créer
une cinquième branche appelé à être
déficitaire comme le sont les autres ça
me paraissait beaucoup plus légitime
d'aborder ce problème là puis surtout
d'attendre plfss pour englober
l'ensemble des financements possibles
sans attendre 3 ans bien sûr peut-être
puisque les 0,15 d'utilisation des cg
affectées à la cades est font l'objet de
la loi ordinaire donc absolument qu'un
obstacle à ce qu'on prête ce problème au
moment du plfss
et puis voir aussi surtout quels sont
les autres sources de financement
possibles parce que entre 8 à 10
milliards et 2 milliards et demi il ya
un delta important donc voilà c'est des
constatations que fait il n'ya pas
réellement de deux questions mais c'est
une analyse peut être un peu béotienne
que je fais mais qui je pense là ne
mérite de l'orthodoxie financière
merci monsieur bonne merci monsieur le
président monsieur ministre oui
les questions sont un peu redondante par
rapport à ce qui a été exposé par notre
rapporteur général et par journal garde
ou mais je voudrais faire trois
remarques ou trois questions
d'abord cinquième risque ou 5ème branche
parce que je pense qu'il ya une grosse
différence entre les deux la 5ème
branche
obligera quand même à ce qu'il y ait un
responsable au niveau de cette 5ème
branche et je re savoir comment vous
l'envisagez si la cinquième manche est
retenue par le gouvernement plutôt que
cinquième risque le cinquième risque
avait davantage de pouvoir être géré
aussi rapidement par le ccri de
l'organiser sécurité sociale et les
parties famille
le deuxième question je reviens un peu
sur les 0 15% parce que tout à l'heure
on entendait le président de la cad est
ce qu'ils nous disaient que il avait
fallu prolonger d'un an la durée de vie
de remboursement pour justement
permettre à ces 0 15% de se mettre en
place à partir de 2024
or est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas pu
prolonger d'un an supplémentaire et
commencer tout de suite le remboursement
lorsque les discussions avec les
financeurs enfin des organismes qui nous
prêtent de l'argent ont bien dû avoir
lieu par rapport au mas la modification
considérable de l'endettement et
notamment des 136 milliards que l'on met
en plus et puis la dernière remarque bon
vous avez parlé du milliard
supplémentaire à partir du plfss 2021
pour 2021 mais un milliard ne permettra
absolument pas de répondre à la
programmation normale de la loi grand
âge dont on devrait parler rapidement
or le secteur et particulièrement en
difficulté et je vais pas anticiper ce
que
ce que nous proposerons en tout cas pour
la loi grand âge mais il faudra quand
même plus de 1 milliard immédiatement et
attendre les 2 milliard 3 ou 2 milliards
4 à partir de 2024
voilà je voulais juste par rapport à ces
remarques compléter un peu les questions
qui avaient été exposées précédemment
merci je vous laisse répondre présent
d'un mec c'est au rapporteur puis après
on passera en question de collègues
monsieur le président de la bad teacher
monsieur car douceur car d'où je me
souviens que vous aviez parlé je peux
pas parler dans le micro et vous
regardez excusez moi on ne m'en veuillez
pas je me souviens vous aviez déjà
évoqué l'idée de reprendre la dette qui
n'avait pas été apurés qui étaient
stockés à la cause c'est que c'était
l'objet de débats l'histoire vous donne
raison monsieur le sénateur et est dès
lors que j'espère que votre et ce projet
de loi l'histoire vous aura donné raison
dans la mesure où cette dette sera
transféré directement directement la
caennaise faute d'avoir pu être apurée
en ligne comme nous aurions pu et
souhaitez le faire il faut se souvenir
que jusqu'à il ya quelques mois je vais
cale du concours à la violence et nous
étions sur un rythme de remboursement
plus rapide que prévu de la dette
sociale
historiquement les textes les tables de
la loi il était indiqué potentiellement
2024 ou 2025 y avait des bals sur cette
question et on était parti plus tôt pour
la rembourser tout début de 1024 qui
fait que je faisais partie de ceux qui
se mobilisent et au parlement
l'assemblée nationale pour proposer
qu'on diminue un peu le rythme de
remboursement pour pouvoir financer les
dépenses de perte d'autonomie
objet de la suite dans les idées le
projet de loi qui vous est présentée
permet de le faire à partir de 2024 par
un mécanisme somme toute assez assez
similaires le financeur pour ajouter un
argument sur la reprise de dette des
hôpitaux par la cad sc que le financeur
principal des hôpitaux c'est l'assurance
maladie et donc encore une fois on est
dans une dans une logique dans une
continuité de financeurs les différences
de taux entre état sécu sont extrêmement
marginale extrêmement marginal est
amenée à évoluer d'ici à 2030 trois ans
qu'on puisse en savoir la direction
et j'ajoute que la cades est rembourse
aux principales contrairement à l'état
qui ne rembourse pas au principal
différence entre branches eric d'abord
il n'ya pas de cinquième risque puisque
des risques en a déjà beaucoup plus que
on parle de cinquième risque est ce qui
est une erreur de langage dans la mesure
où il n'a plus que cinq par contre
débrancher n'a que 4 et l' avantage de
créer une cinquième branche j'imagine
c'est ce que celle avantages qu'ils ont
trouvé les les députés c'est que ça
permet d'identifier un risque qui n'est
d'ailleurs pas le cinquième j'insiste
mais le neuvième pour être tout à fait
précis et déjà lui risque c'est que et
elle permet d'en assurer une gestion
autonome et identifier ce qui permet de
consacrer à la perte d'autonomie une
importance particulière et d'éviter sa
dilution au sein d'une branche déjà
existante avec d'autres risques les
sénateurs seront évidemment concerné
concerter sur les travaux en cours sur
la gouvernance et sur la question des
recettes vient la conférence des
financeurs ne pouvait pas en être
autrement et j'y veillerai et j'entends
les remarques du sénateur bonne sur le
fait qu'un milliard soit insuffisant
j'ai jamais dit que c'était suffisant
j'ai même dit le contraire c'est pas un
milliard pour celle de tout compte déjà
plus de 23 milliards d'euros par an
c'est un milliard supplémentaire qui
nous permet d'engager une réforme
notamment une politique de l'offre qui
fera l'objet d'un projet de loi à doc
qui vous sera présenté
qui parlera à la perte d'autonomie et si
il venait à l'idée des parlementaires
d'identifier d'autres sources de
financement toute aide est précieuse en
la matière mais honnêtement un milliard
de plus sur une année à venir
c'est pas ne s'est pas négligeable
j'ajoute que le gouvernement a déjà
mille neuf cent millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour les ehpad à travers
la crise coded la moitié environ pour la
prime est votre moitié pour soutenir les
ehpad qui ont fait face à des
difficultés puisque arrêt d admission
coups qui ont été complétés majoré ce
qu'était un effort encore une fois
important en fait les efforts financiers
qu'ont été fait je m'en rends compte
dans le champ de la protection sociale
au cours de la crise qu vide ne sont
sans doute pas aussi visible que s'il
avait été fait en dehors de toute crise
parce qu'ils ont été prises sont des
décisions qui ont été rapides massives
prises dans une actualité qui me
laissait peu de place au débat
budgétaire et c'est tout à fait normal
sachez que mis bout-à-bout les sur
dépenses de sécurité sociale à la fois
pour le chant des ehpad pour les plus
précaires les primes alimentaires ont
dépassé les 3 milliards d'euros par
rapport à ce qui avait été budgété signe
qu' il ya quand même une réactivité très
forte au milliard d'euros c'est
absolument pas négligeable sur une
période de deux 2 mois et demi environ
voilà pour les réponses monsieur prison
et monsieur nice alors je vais passer
maintenant au collègue monsieur chasse à
ceux chassaing faut appuyer sur le
bouton vert il a est ce qu'il est
il est inhérent corrèze
monsieur mais oui très bien
vas-y vas-y vont très bien merci
monsieur le président monsieur ministre
donc mes chers collègues je vais poser
trois questions donc pour moi la
politique de l'indépendance avec le 5e
risque bon pour moi parce qu'une bonne
nouvelle j'aime même ont été à plusieurs
quand même pas espérer que ça arriverait
avant les retraites le la loi sur les
retraites puisque le président la
république l'avait déclaré en 2018 alors
monsieur le ministre la la il vous avez
dans cette loi l'impossibilité
effectivement d'affecter de la cades est
ce qu'on la dépendance avant 2024 et
vous affectez 0 15 % c'est-à-dire
environ 2 millions d'euros en 2024
c'est vraiment très insuffisant parce
que nous avons vous le savez d'ailleurs
d une dépendance très importante en
ehpad et nous avons un encadrement 0,6
alors qu'il faudrait aller rapidement au
moins 0,7 ou 0,8
alors madame de mon champ j'ai bien
écouté dans son jeu j'ai bien écouté son
audition elle nous dit que il y avait
peut-être des possibilités quand même
avec la scène et ça pour affecter des
sommes dès 2021 pour la prise en charge
de la dépendance
effectivement ça ça paraît tout à fait
indispensable parce que les personnes
n'arrivent plus en ehpad à prendre en
charge de façon indécente
donc nos aînés et je souhaiterais aussi
évoqué la possibilité dans la loi que le
conseil départemental soit l'intérêt
l'interlocuteur unique pour l'ensemble
de l'offre médico social c'est à dire
que le département s'occupe à la fois de
l'année
annoncée du soin qui est délégation
d'état c'est dans le cadre d'une
décentralisation est aussi qui conserve
bien sûr le budget hébergement et en
plus ce troisième question sur la
formation
je pense que on a une carence de
formation parce que on a besoin de
beaucoup d'aidé soignante et
l'infirmière elle la vae est
insuffisamment connue notamment pour
devenir de l'apprentissage n'est pas
développé défense qu'est ce que vous
allez faire pour essayer de débloquer
rapidement la formation merci merci bien
si j'ai bien compris monsieur chassaing
il est favorable à une loi sur
l'autonomie plutôt qu'un article
subsidiaire à une loi sur la cades est
ce monsieur mouillé merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre alors je
voulais simplement d'abord commencé par
un témoignage et quelques questions
lorsque le débat a été lancé l'assaut
national de ce texte sur la création de
cette branche de tonneaux me il a créé
un engouement fort et important près des
stations du monde de handicap
cet engouement est temps par contre un
peu diluée au fur et à mesure des débats
par manque de visibilité sur le contenu
de cette de cette réforme
ça renvoie votre amour envoie plusieurs
à calendrier avec un rapport au mois de
septembre dans laquelle on imagine les
contours à la loi de finances donc pour
avoir les prélèvements chiffrée mais le
grand manque de ce texte même dans cette
phase là d'introduction ces convois
papillon pas les contours de la
politique d'autonomie que voulait porter
ni finalement les grandes orientations
financières que vous souhaitez mettre en
place avec derrière tout ça la grande
question pour le monde du handicap du
débat du reste à charge est un point
essentiel alors trois questions peu
particulier à la première c'est voir
comment on appelle sur comment sont
associés des structures les sessions du
monde handicap dans la sélection de la
rédaction du rapport du mois de
septembre
c'est ma première question deuxième
question sommes nous bien réellement
dans un texte qui concerne l'autonomie
et ou uniquement l'aspect vieillissement
à travers les plats père de l'autonomie
parce que c'est une anse importante plus
mon handicap
le poème de l'autonomie c'est tous les
âges
et c'est pas uniquement le début du
vieillissement et je pense qu'il serait
difficile de saucissonner j'irai le
l'enjeu du handicap à travers des
problématiques d'âge mais c'est bien un
débat de père de tonnes mais général
donc comment est-ce qu'on croise cela
avec le texte sur le vieillissement des
personnes et dernier volet c'est pensez
vous que à travers votre volonté
politique nous allons passer d'une
logique dette sociale à une logique de
prestations sociales
merci bien je vais donc passer la parole
à monsieur théophile en saluant nos
collègues des caraïbes qui sont à
nouveau en présence avec nous et en leur
adressant nos excuses pour les avoir
obligées à se lever à 4 heures du matin
les autres fois monsieur lui oui quand
les réunions se déroulent à 9h30 les
trois heures et demie chez nous monsieur
le ministre vous avez évoqué a déjà
plusieurs reprises la la l'idée
d'abonder d'un milliard de 2021 jusqu'à
2024 et vous l'avez préciser tout à
l'heure puisque c'était une précision
que je vous demandais mais vous avez dit
que vous attendiez des parlementaires
aussi un peu des dépôts position et ma
question était puisque c'est une somme
pour tenter avez vous déjà justement
puisque nous sommes à quelques mois pour
évoquer avoue déjà des pistes des
milliards pour abonder la la la scène
est là la branche avant 2024
merci bien ai je donc donné la parole à
madame apourceau poly
ac j'ai complètement oublié
merci monsieur le président donc
monsieur le ministre
comme vous l'avez fort bien dit la
réforme sur l'autonomie est évidemment
très attendu il faut donc la faire nous
pensons je pense pour ma part et la
bâtir évidemment toute concertation avec
les véritables décideurs et ça a été dit
avec ceux et celles qui travaillent dans
le secteur de l'autonomie mais également
du médico social
alors vous avez dit monsieur le ministre
que vous prévoyez d'affecter 2 4
milliards d'euros à la caisse de
solidarité pour l'autonomie csa pour
amorcer donc le chantier grand âge ainsi
je me tourne alors que les estimations
sont de 8 1 16 milliard d'euros 1 des
estimations aujourd'hui alors vous
l'avez dit avec donc une nouvelle
branche donc de la sécurité sociale donc
j'aimerais savoir comment vous allez
financer si on prend la fourchette la
plus basse des estimations de 8
milliards d'euros
comment vous allez financer les 5,6
milliards d'euros manquants est ce que
vous allez vous attaquer aux et puis
mettre à contribution les revenus
financiers
est ce que vous allez mettre à
contribution les revenus les plus aisés
est ce que en créant une cotisation sur
les bénévoles à les mettre en place une
cotisation sur les bénéfices des
industriels du médicament
donc j'aimerais un peu savoir comment
vous allez financer si on prend donc
cette fourchette la plus basse des 5,6
milliards d'euros qu'il va manquer et
sur l'utilité de créer une cinquième
branche
que pensez vous de l'idée de créer un
risque dépendance au sein de la branche
assurance maladie et ensuite une
dernière question sur la gouvernance
donc de ceux de cette 5ème branche
pourquoi ne pas créer d créer ce
primaire de l'autonomie avec donc une
gestion paritaire organisations
syndicales organisation patrie
patronale ce serait aux organisations
syndicales de s'adapter pour proposer
des délégués en lien avec l'autonomie
est pareil évidemment pour les
organisations patronales
je vous remercie merci je vous laisse
répondre à cette première sage monsieur
ministre je vais peut-être répondre dans
le désordre et de façon non nominatifs
pour essayer de 2,6 m'en excuser pour
essayer d'organiser un peu le la réponse
je vais peut-être commencer par la fin
d'ailleurs les 8 milliards d'euros c'est
d'ici à 2030 donc je n'ai pas encore la
solution sur le financement la perte
d'autonomie d'ici à 10 6 à 10 ans ça
nous laisse un petit peu de temps pour y
travailler même s'il faut évidemment
identifier ces solutions avant et qu'on
sait qu'il y aurait une montée en charge
progressive parce que les dépenses les
besoins monétaires vont s'accroître
année après année toutes les pistes sont
sur la table a menacé la crise juste
rappeler quand vous parliez de taxer le
capital ou les bénéfices que la csg qui
est aujourd'hui une mode de financement
que nous privilégions à travers cette
cette nouvelle de nouvelles notations
pèsent sur le capital et sur le
patrimoine à proportion créer une
nouvelle strate administrative d'
agences territoriales
moi je vous dirais que je suis plutôt
défavorable je considère qu'on a déjà un
millefeuille administratif qui est assez
copieux en inclinaison naturelle c'est
plutôt d'essayer de simplifier les
organisations territoriales du total et
recréer des nouveaux dispositifs et je
pense qu'on peut s'appuyer sur les
réseaux existants pour les développer et
permettent de traiter la question de la
perte d'autonomie dans les territoires
sur les modalités de l'identification du
milliard comment est-ce qu'on va
financer milliards ce sera l'objet du
prochain plfss je ne vous le présente
pas aujourd'hui parce que j'en ai pas
encore le contenu et j'ai une mission
qui est en cours on lui en ai parlé tout
à l'heure pour identifier les pistes de
financement ya plein d'exemples j'ai
entendu des exemples intéressants comme
à les mettre à contribution de fonds de
réserve des retraites ce genre de choses
là il ya d'autres possibilités qui
seront j'imagine examiné par le
rapporteur de cette mission qui encore
une fois viendra à votre rencontre
sur la perte d'autonomie je confirme que
c'est bien l'âge plus le handicap pour
ça que nous ait retenu l'appellation
perte d'autonomie et j'ai pas appeler ça
un plan dépendance ou une case et
pendant ses biens l'association des 2
l'ensemble des associations des acteurs
dans une jambe dans le champ de la perte
d'autonomie sont évidemment associés à
la réflexion aux travaux de a à z leur
impatience est grande elle est
compréhensible
leur envie d'avancer tout temps et donc
je considère que c'est un encore une
fois on parle ici d'un texte budgétaire
qui transfèrent des déficits à une
caisse mais mais c'est
c'est un très beau projet qui est en
train de se dessiner à travers à travers
cela c'est la question de l'autonomie du
maintien l'autonomie d'ailleurs il
faudrait qu'on arrête de parler de perte
d'autonomie puisque c'est péjoratif
on est plutôt dans le maintien la
préservation la prévention de de
l'autonomie
et puis sur toutes les grandes questions
vous avez posé encore une fois qu'ils
sont légitimes sur les règles
d'encadrement delà le mot dépendance a
été utilisée aussi mais surtout sur
toutes ces questions la semaine d'été de
financement sur la gouvernance hacker
département les ars etc
c'est vraiment pas l'objet de ce texte
je pense qu'on aura largement l'occasion
d'en débattre sur le fond c'est des
questions qui sont importantes
je propose revenir peut-être à l'essence
même de ce texte parce que sinon vous
pourrez divaguer divaguer vous savez que
je suis bavard je vois le président
milon qui qui me regardent
mais si j'aime passionne mais je crois
que c'est pas l'objet de ce projet doit
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur et
nous on va prendre la suite
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez évoqué l'urgence un
pour motiver les choix qui sont faits
par le gouvernement
il n'en reste pas moins vrai que c'est
notre rôle de parlementaire de
comprendre la pertinence et la cohérence
donc sans déborder mais quand même un
peu plus que ses questions étaient
posées
le 22 avril où je pense qu'on avait
interrogé auditionner les ministes
darmana et on lui avait posé la question
de savoir quel honda me proposerait si
le plfss c'était un plfss rectificatif
et il nous avait répondu 6 5% je crois
et donc je vous renvoie à nouveau cette
cette question à aujourd'hui
et ensuite l'interrogation qui est la
mienne c'est par rapport au périmètre du
ségur
est-ce que la tuyauterie du plfss est
dans le périmètre du ségur et aussi
l'articulation par rapport à cette
question ce ce projet de loi est ce
qu'il aurait pas mieux fallu aborder
cette question de l'autonomie à
l'occasion du ségur
plutôt que de précipiter même si je
comprends que des personnes attendent
cette question de l'autonomie à
l'occasion de de ce projet de loi ce qui
fait qu'on va peut-être prendre tes des
décisions qui mériterait d'être
approfondie comme par exemple la place
de la cns
voilà je développe pas plus mais voilà
les questions que je souhaite aborder
je vous remercie madame meunier
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre j'avais une question qui
ressemblait fort à celle de notre
collègue philippe moullier sur le
périmètre et la répartition entre
handicap et à je vous avais été plus
précis donc là c'est quand même l'âge
plus le handicap
donc on va reconnaître la question du
seuil partir de quel âge un bon vous
savez c'est ce qu' on reconnaît est ce
qu'on a comme expérience dans les
départements 1 entre l'as pas après 65
ans donc est ce que vous pensez pas que
vous allez vous remettre là dedans
et ceci dit les personnes handicapées
représentés par leurs associations sont
aussi
enfin je pense pas qu'elle ait compris
ce que vous nous avez dit c'est
clairement tout de suite donc il ya de
la tente
vous le savez du point de vue humain a
pas des personnes et des associations
qui se sont regroupés en différents
collectifs
moi je voulais vous parler donc des
recettes est ce que vous avez des pistes
de financement vous allez le lire après
mais parce qu'on entend pas mal de
choses dans nos auditions on reparle de
des droits de succession du 1 % c'est
une idée que monsieur li bo trouve
personnellement intéressantes sur ce qui
est succession qui rapporterait de
manière quasi indolore sur les
transactions successorale si on
fonctionnait 1%
voilà ça c'est une idée il la cfdt on a
une autre sur la taxation plus
importante des donations voilà donc
est-ce que vous avez vous dégagez ou
entrevue des pistes supplémentaires de
financement sur ce cinquième 5ème
branche monsieur d'audi merci monsieur
le président monsieur nice je vais
revenir sur un sujet général déjà
évoquée mais que je pense important
parce qu'il touche à la philosophie et à
la nature de la sécurité sociale nous
avions cru comprendre les mois dernier
que le gouvernement n'était pas attaché
plus que cela le rapporteur général a
dit à l'autonomie de la sécurité sociale
et vous l'aviez manifester en ne
compensant plus toutes les suppressions
de cotisation vous l'aviez aussi
manifesté en envisageant de retransféré
les excédents de service social vers le
budget de l'état or sur un une dette
dont vous même vous avez dit que la
nature pouvait être sujet à discussion
qui concerne des pertes de recettes qui
concerne un événement extraordinaire
mondial sur cette dette exceptionnelle
vous revenez à l'autonomie de la
sécurité sociale en considérant que
cette date est une dette sociale
il n'est pas possible monsieur le
ministre considérait que l'autonomie
d'assuré social existe lorsqu'il s'agit
de dette et qu'elle n'existe pas dans
les autres de circonstance question de
philosophie et d'avenir qui est
importante pour la sécurité sociale pour
la deuxième question monsieur le
ministre vous allez certainement et je
vous le souhaite donc attaché votre nom
à la création de la cinquième branche de
la sécurité sociale
c'est un événement historique alors la
sécurité sociale
subi de nombreuses modifications depuis
1945 mais c'est la première fois qu'une
branche supplémentaire va être créée
après les quatre autres alors monsieur
le ministre comment expliquer qu'un
évènement d'une telle importance d'une
telle portée arrive dans le débat à
l'occasion d'un amendement déposé sur un
article qui concernait un rapport du
gouvernement
il eût été préférable d'un évidemment
que un pan entier du plfss soit consacré
à cette mesure avec une discussion
complète sur la gouvernance sur les
recettes sur les prestations avec toute
la solennité qui aurait pu être dégagée
ça ne peut pas être le cas dans ces
circonstances où il y à un amalgame
entre le traitement d'une dette ce qui
est en soi un événement qui n'est pas
porteur de pensée très agréable même si
elles sont obligatoires ses pensées avec
la création donc la prise en compte
d'une demande de la société qui est une
demande ans y est ancienne et à laquelle
vous allez répondre et à priori puisque
vous avez indiqué qu'il s'agissait de à
la fois âge et handicap
vous allez y répondre je le souhaite de
la façon la plus appréciée par tout le
monde donc pourquoi ces circonstances
vraiment étonnante dans le
fonctionnement du parlement et dans l'
annonce d'un tel événement je vous
remercie
merci bien madame lubat à prendre la
suite merci monsieur le président en
fait je me suis ministre je ne je
n'aurais pas dit mieux forcément que
yves daudigny
c'est exactement la même question est la
même teneur l'arrivée de cette création
de 5ème branche dans ces circonstances
me paraît totalement incongrue et
j'allais être du coup
poser deux questions liées à la place du
conseil départemental éolien avec le
handicap mais comme vous avez dit que
vous ne souhaitiez pas vous éloigner de
l'esprit de ce texte je les poserait pas
j'en resterai là mais simplement
monsieur le ministre
comprenez bien que une telle annonce ne
nous ne nous laisse pas de poser des
questions j'ai envie de dire il est
évident qu'on ne va pas se contenter de
savoir ce que vous allez financer
comment vous allez le financer ce qui
nous intéresse également
c'est ce que vous allez mettre dans
cette danse est 5e branché et la façon
dont tout cela va s'articuler avec ce
qui existe déjà et dans l'avenir c'est
bien pour ça que nous appelons de nos
voeux quand même un débat est un débat
oui mais j'ai envie de dire là on met la
charrue avant les boeufs très clairement
bon allez chalet bleu vont la pousser
monsieur savary et rend la bourre avec
les vieux cons là on est dans nos
territoires ruraux
non monsieur le ministre je partage je
vais rejoindre je vais je vais rejoindre
mais mes collègues et moi je trouve
qu'il ya une incohérence par rapport à
cette loi est maintenant une cinquième
branche qui serait même dirigé par la
cns a d'ailleurs vous avez dit vous même
au départ vous aviez parlé d'un
cinquième risque éventuel que vous
commenceriez à financer à travers le
0,15 à travers 2024 bon c'est un
affichage
pourquoi pas moi je dirais même pourquoi
pas ça peut se discuter mais pourquoi
passe un texte financier mais on en
profite pour afficher une volonté très
bien mais là attendez l'assemblée
nationale tout moment on nous parle de
5ème branche on travaille des gens si
l'eau on a des problèmes entre le
sanitaire médico-social le privé le
public
on l'a déjà évoqué c'est toujours pas
réglé la médecine de ville la médecine
hospitalière exercent et toujours pas
réglé on aurait pu penser que à travers
la crise que l'on vient de connaître à
travers le ségur on aurait pu envisager
un modèle social adapter au xxième
siècle on parle pas du déficit de
l'unedic il fait pas partie du périmètre
de
sécurité sociale les régimes
complémentaires à ils font pas partie
s'était proposé le texte de loi
c'est la retraite je t'ai de loi sur la
retraite il est pour l'instant comprend
également différer différent mais c'est
pas dans le périmètre encore de la
sécurité sociale on continue à
fonctionner au silo et on connaît les
difficultés on apprend que c'est
l'autonomie
moi c'est ce que j'avais compris aussi
quand même on avait compris que c'était
l'autonomie quel que soit l'âge donc
handicap plus personnes âgées
on connaît les difficultés ça veut dire
que de toute façon dans toutes ses
dimensions là il ya une dimension
transversale pour les personnes âgées
l'autonomie des personnes âgées la
branche vieillesse participent déjà
largement trentaine de milliards d'euros
continuons à verser dans le monde du
handicap il ya au sida selon l'âge de
neuf personnes handicapées il ya la
branche famille etc
vous n'échapperez pas des dimensions
transversale à ont créé une cinquième
manche sans avoir mesuré l'impact et
elle sera dirigée par la scène et ça je
connais bien cet organisme j'ai été j'ai
des prisons département je sais comment
on travaille et c'est comme d'autres
j'ai rien inventé mais véritablement ça
mérite d'étudier la place de chacun des
partenaires ça mérite un impact et vous
nous dites là ah ben non on verra ça
c'est pas dans la loi mais c'est dans la
loi puisque c était transformé ce une
cinquième branche est qui sera dirigée
par le cns a donc l'optique d'un texte
budgétaire on est transformé en expose
en texte sociétale moi ça me pose des
questions
donc c'est je voulais vous faire part de
ses préoccupations de façon très
officielle
et deuxièmement maintenant on en revient
à la loi initial si vous permettez à
savoir la dette sociale amortie par la
calèche de façon supplémentaire 136
milliards au global dont 92 milliard de
dettes prévisionnelles dans ses 92
milliards quelle est la part du
sanitaire quelle est la part pour les
retraites parce qu'on sait qu'il va y
avoir un déficit important dans la vie
le corps il ya 25 milliards alors qu'on
n'était qu'à 10 milliard et quelle est
la part à ce moment-là de déficit
prévisionnel de la cinquième manche
puisque vous parlez d'une cinquième
branche est qui sera mis en application
donc on prévoit un déficit prévisionnel
aussi de cette cinquième manche ou pas
comment vous anticipez tout cela je vous
laisse répondre monsieur le ministre la
richesse des questions fait qu'à la fin
on a presque oublié la première mais
néanmoins j'ai pris trois notes sur la
question de l'andam c'est pour le
sénateur raynaud si je me souviens bien
quelle sera l'évolution en taux de
l'ondam je vais vous dire une chose
parler d'évolution de l'andam je pense
qu'il faut qu'on arrête antho je sais
pas pourquoi un moment donné on a
déterminé je chercherai dans les
grimoires de la sécu mais à quel moment
est-ce qu'on a considéré qu'il fallait
qu'on parle d'évolution en taux de
l'ondam en pourcentage errer sur l'autre
je vous donnerai pas tant général de la
sécu je suis pas sûr que ça fasse sens
je veux donner un exemple cette année
avec l'ondam qu'on va avoir du fait de
la crise qu vide
l'évolution du taux avait tout le monde
a regardé mais du coup l'année prochaine
l'année prochaine l'évolution du taux de
l'ondam en question en fait vu le niveau
de dépenses qu'on a eu cette année ya
peu de chances qu'on ait le même niveau
l'année prochaine on fait en dames
négatif alors qu'on aura plus de 200
milliards d'euros sur la table donc je
pense qu'il faut qu'on arrête de parler
en évolution du taux de l'ondam c'est un
espèce d'indicateur qui honnêtement ne
veut pas dire grand chose et qu'on parle
dont dame en euros et en même temps
c'est peut-être une façon aussi pour les
contribuables qui cotisent à la sécu de
se rendre compte de ce qu'il ya derrière
le monde ondam
il ya un rapport très très intéressant
de monsieur savary même de roche sur yon
dame a bien
j'ai connu six au sénat on donnait même
pas le solde en valeur absolue des
l'assurance maladie des caisses d'autre
part les canto et puis en solde négatif
au positif on ne donnait pas les valeurs
absolues et donc c'est vrai que c'est
important
vous avez le dos et un indic est un
indicateur va mal je vous dis tu veux
dire sénat je pense que c'est plus
parlant pour les français de savoir
qu'on dépense 206 milliards d'euros pour
la santé cette année que 2,3 pour cent
d'accord mais il faut on dépense 206
milliards je crois je peux pas dire de
bêtises on dépense 206 milliards au saut
bono cette année pour la santé avant le
coc vide pour la santé des français
ça ça parle donc parlons euros sur la
question du plfss et du ségur c'est pas
c'est pas le lieu de parler du plfss le
ségur déjà chantier monumental qu'on a
concentré dans un temps très court avec
une concertation très forte et pour
laquelle je souhaite que nous
aboutissions dans les quinze jours qui
viennent néanmoins on va aborder on va
glisser sur le champ de l'autonomie
puisque il sera question de la
revalorisation des salaires dans les
ehpad des soignants et ce qui est une
façon très forte d'aborder la question
la question d'autonomie pour la
sénatrice meunier oui la chaîne entre le
handicap est davantage chasse est une
épine dans le pied des pouvoirs publics
depuis des années c'est très compliqué
j'imagine que la question se posera j'en
parlerai avec la secrétaire d'état
sophie cluzel est que les associations
va j'en reparlerai il suffit pas d'en
parler on sait très bien quels sont les
enjeux et qui sont importants et
probablement qu'à la faveur de la
création de cette branche ce sont des
questions qui pourront être être reposé
en tout cas j'imagine
et sur la question du financement j'ai
déjà répondu maintenant sénatrice que je
ne répondrai pas puisqu'il ya une
mission spécifique sur ces questions là
et que j'ai abordés comme ça une piste
il y en ad'autres vous en avez abordé
une sur le 1% sur les dmtg sur les
transmissions gras de titres gratuits
qui est une piste aussi voilà il ya
plein de pistes à fourmille d'idées pour
financer pour financer la question de
l'autonomie apa d'argent magique et pas
d'argent gratuit toute façon il va
falloir l'identifier
sur le port le sénateur jean j'ai déjà
répondu statut de la dette qu vite je ne
m'y arrête pas vous ne m'en voudrez pas
et puis question que vous avez été
plusieurs imposé j'ai envie de répondre
l'occasion fait le larron mais je crois
que c'est péjoratif comme expression
mais c'était but pour dire on a sauté
sur l'occasion pour pouvoir réaliser une
promesse qui a été faite et répété
depuis plus de dix ans et qui n'a jamais
été réalisé l'identification
l'identification d'un nouveau oui la
raison elle était budgétaire monsieur le
sénateur je peux vous donner
l'excellente roselyne bachelot elle même
on avait convenu à ses dépens
l'excellente la non moins excellente
michèle delaunay des ceux qui l'ont
précédé et suivi l'on est également dit
de la problèmes de financement et donc
jamais jamais la promesse de création d'
enrichissement de la sécurité sociale
par avec l'identification d'un risque
pour la perte d'autonomie et d'une
branche en l'occurrence n'avait été
réalisée on aurait pu encore considéré
qu'on attendrait dix ans supplémentaires
et que nous verrions plus tard là moi je
suis je vous le dis absolument fier est
absolument convaincu que ces moments de
le faire parce que vous ne faites pas
que cela vous étendre le périmètre du
plfss à cette question de l'autonomie ce
qui permet à la représentation nationale
de débattre à chaque automne du
financement de la question d'autonomie
un débat dont vous étiez plus ou moins
privé jusqu'à présent et le lacrosse
organique dans la loi nous permet de
créer cela sinon il aurait fallu une
nouvelle loi organique ad-hoc pour
pouvoir créer cela avant d'avoir un
plfss pour pour le financer ensuite
avant enfin de poser une loi haddock sur
l'autonomie va écouter non on n'aura
plus besoin la première étape elle est
devant vous et vous pouvez la beauté
c'est la création d'une nouvelle branche
la loi organique
elle est là derrière le plfss à la
rentrée et derrière une loi haddock sur
l'autonomie donc enfin on avance la
perte d'autonomie c'est comme pardon
mais c'est comme le colis dans la perte
d'autonomie c'est digne droite ni de
gauche ni en marche dire que les
ministres successifs ont tous dit on ne
veut renforcer le périmètre de la sécu
qu'ils soient de gauche ou de droite les
ministres successifs ont toujours dit on
n'a pas beaucoup d'argent mais quand on
en aura on va là on le fera et tout le
monde a dit il faudra bien de faire
toute façon avant 2024 2025 parce
qu'après le mur démocratique arrive
écoutez c'est un travail voyez le comme
un travail collectif porté années après
par les gouvernements successifs et que
j'espère j'espère rencontrera la
sentiment favorable d'une majorité
écrasante des parlementaires c'était le
cas à l'assemblée sur cette question là
le texte a été rejeté dans l'ensemble
c'est dommage symboliquement parce que
les historiens se pencheront sur la
question de l'élargissement du périmètre
de laisser quelques une nouvelle manche
mais c'est la première fois depuis 45
c'est la première fois depuis 45 qu'on
élargit le périmètre non mais attendez
c'est une question c'est pas une
question qui est neutre en termes
d'impact c'est un neuvième risque et une
cinquième branche vous avez les deux
vous avez les deux cherchez bien dans
les archives depuis 45 le discours de la
roque et de je regarde de l'hémisphère
gauche le côté gauche est évidemment
ambroise croizat
mais le discours à part dont le gers et
patrick communiste mais la question
le discours pierre laroque l'avait dit à
l'époque quand il avait fait sur dix co
fondateur il avait dit aujourd'hui la
sécurité sociale doit protéger le
travailleur de tout risque qui pourrait
l'empêcher de gagner sa vie par son
travail il avait identifié des risques
de la maladie la famille la question de
l'âge et des retraites et les maladies
professionnelles
il avait dit avec le temps d'autres
risques surviendront qu'il nous faudra
couvrir élargir le périmètre faisons le
peu importe le moment faisons le jeu
cieux jeudi sur ce point donc c'est
clair la réponse monsieur le ministre
est favorable à la création de la 5ème
branche ont été votées à l'assemblée
nationale j'imagine avec l'assentiment
du gouvernement
bon donc ça y'a pas de mystère pourquoi
pas c'est vrai que ça peut être
présentée un peu la souhaite nous c'est
la première pierre vous avez dit
première pierre pourrait tout pourquoi
pas effectivement dans le cadre de cette
loi organique pourquoi pas le vrai
problème c'est effectivement le
financement et c'est ça le vrai problème
donc bon on a une information nouvelle
il y aura il n'y aura pas il n'y aura
pas d 2021
une partie des deux milliards trois cent
gmail y aura 1 milliards qui sera donnée
à cette 5ème branche dans le plfss pour
quand même une information intéressante
un milliard c'est insuffisant mais c'est
un pro
gray nous pensions certains d'entre nous
j'ai écouté tout à l'heure les hôtes que
si si si on avait six vous supprimiez
les 13 milliards d'affecter à la cades
est ce ça permettait de transférer dès
2021 les 2.3 milliards avec le même
équilibre pour la cades s en termes de
durée d'amortissement
faites le calcul donc je dis il y avait
d'autres solutions il y avait d'autres
solutions pour permettre un financement
plus rapide puisque vous y tenez
beaucoup à cette 5ème branche
maintenant il faudra définir j'espère
que le rapport servira à ça ça sera pas
un rapport je dirais évasif définir
quels sont les risques et les
financements qui sont repris dans la
cinquième manche
tout à fait il ne gagne 1,66 milliard on
a bien écoutez madame montchamp qui se
félicite évidemment de devenir pilote de
cette branche peut la comprendre
d'ailleurs mais dia 66 milliards
aujourd'hui dépensées pour l'autonomie
et le handicap
et il y en a green 2 vous le savez très
bien dans la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale sur les mêmes risques
donc il ya une différence considérable
ça va du tiers c'est deux fois plus
trois fois plus soit deux fois plus
pardon mais en mieux
oui c'est bien trois fois plus trompe
pas donc le problème il est là je pense
qu'il serait intéressant pour éclairer
le sénat monsieur le ministre nous
n'êtes pas ce soir dans tous les cas
pourquoi pas avant demain matin est ce
que monsieur mais d'apporter des
précisions sur ce point je pense qu'il
serait de nature à lever effectivement
des doutes chez certains sur la volonté
d'aller au delà de l'effet d'annoncé
mais réellement d'engager très
rapidement et vous avez déjà donné un
signe important
un milliard c'est pas rien dans le plfss
mais j'aimerais que
on puisse aller plus vite encore en
besogne dans cette affaire ces avaries
précisé le rien je fais la différence
entre le risque et la branche organisé
par leur scène et ça quant à grande j'ai
demandé la répartition des 92 milliards
de déficit prévisionnel
c'est le rapporteur qui l'a empêché de
parler
jallet jallet j'allais rester j'allais
lui rendant la justice du président
bilan parce que j'ai pas eu le temps de
vous répondre sur l'essai en fait c'est
52 milliards parce que les cas il ya une
partie que vous connaissez vous
identifier et donc il ya 52 milliards
sur le sur le déficit de la sécurité
sociale pour cette année en cours il ya
31 milliards pour la branche maladie
14 9 milliards pour la branche
vieillesse 3,1 milliards pour la branche
naf 2,1 pour la branche fsv et 0.7 pour
la branche at mp toutes les branches
sont en déficit ce qui n'est pas une
grande surprise
ben vous avez vous ajoutez les 39 vous
ajouter les 30 milliards de la cause
d'ajouter des 13 milliards de la dette
de la sécu vous ajoutez une partie de
dépenses à venir d'investissement dans
le champ de la santé je n'en dirai pas
plus vous ajoutez ensuite le déficit
prévisionnel
maintenant on est à ça on n'était fait à
50 on est on est on est on est un si
vous me laissez terminer ma réponse je
vais essayer d'être plus précis vous
avez 52 milliards comme vous nous
connaissez je présume il a trouvé leur
est dû je viens de vous indiquer le
reste je suis mieux 836 c'est à dire que
vous avez vous avez des 52 milliards de
déficit actuel vous avez les 30
milliards qui était à la tête de la
dette cumulée de la cause à fin 2010 9
je me répète un des 13 milliard de
reprise de la dette des hôpitaux
vous avez une partie investissements à
venir sur la santé vous avez l'aller
vous avez l'équivalent des 13 milliards
qui sont les 2 3 milliards par an à
partir de 2024 sûr c'est plus que ça
d'ailleurs sur le transfert de csg de là
kds vers la scène et ça et vous avez
environ 40 milliards de dette flottante
appelons-la flottante si vous voulez qui
correspond au déficit non consulté la
curd actuelle reproduisant à c'est un
mécanisme qui a été bien qui a été
exploité en qui a été exploité en 2011
et qui portait sur 59 me semble-t-il
milliards à l'époque qui te dire tant
que la dette tant que les déficits
sociaux ne sont pas consolidées qui
encore du chômage partiel
on n'est pas sorti de l'épidémie ont
fait un provisionnement supplémentaire
donc permettre de couvrir les risques à
venir c'est un ajustement qui a été fait
par les prévisionnistes économistes qui
sont beaucoup plus intelligents que moi
et qui est qu'ils sont capables
d'estimer quel sera le montant des
dépenses à venir où cette année où sous
les années à venir dit c'est la fin du
remboursement de la dette
khales merci il attendait disons 10 ont
peut-être revoir un peu le financement
de la grèce ou simplement la durée
d'amortissement le sénateur ce monsieur
rapporteur crois pas que ce soit un
problème le financement de la dépendance
je crois que c'est un enjeu je ne suis
pas je suis attaché ça peut vous
paraître ça peut vous surprendre mais je
suis très attaché à ce que l'état paye
ses dettes et la sécu aussi et j'ai
surtout très attaché à ce qu'on engage
pas de dépense aujourd'hui que nous ne
soyons pas nous mêmes en mesure de
rembourser
j'ai toujours été horripilé par les
mesures qu'ils considéraient est à faire
peser sur dans 10 ans ou dans vingt ans
sur 30 ans des mesures que ce soit des
questions le relative à la retraite par
exemple ou à d'autres fiscalité dont on
dit les gens payeront plus tard moi je
considère que ce qu'on dépense
aujourd'hui on doit prévoir de le payer
aujourd'hui
peut-être est-ce là je me mets encore
dans la génération à la fin de la
génération y mais tout de même dedans
mais j'estime qu'on doit faire très
attention à cela
très attention à cela parce que je ne
sais pas si par exemple l'espérance de
vie va augmenter d'ici vingt ou trente
ans autant qu'elle a augmenté au cours
des 20 ou 30 dernières années parce que
je suis partie d'une génération qui a
connu le chômage de masse l'épidémie
maintenant le terrorisme le
réchauffement climatique et que
peut-être que cette génération a aussi
le droit de ne pas avoir cumulé sur sa
tête pour l'aider
ses nuits à venir un certain nombre
d'impôts qui augmenterait ou de durée de
travail comment ma conception de la
dépense publique c'est qu'il faut être
capable de la corrélée avec des
financements aujourd'hui donc pour moi
c'est je vous dis tout en disant cela je
reconnais et je confesse avoir déjà
anticipé un mécanisme de financement
pour après 2024 mais on est dans un
mécanisme qui permet un remboursement
d'une aide sociale et qui nous confère
dix ans pour trouver des solutions
vis-à-vis pour pour compléter hauteur il
faut qu'on ait ce débat sur le
financement
il faut qu'on ait ce débat jamais
dépendre la perte d'autonomie n'est la
faute à personne
bon nous vieillissons et le baby boom
devient papy boom et nous devons à nos
aînés des soins de qualité un
accompagnement de qualité en respectant
les volontés des personnes et des
individus ça coûte de l'argent
il faut que nous ayons se travaille
ensemble et courageux courageux et aller
devant les français en leur disant voilà
l'enjeu
voilà ce que nous faisons nous
améliorons l'anc et d'encadrement dans
les ehpad
nous renforçons le secteur du domicile
nous aménageons les domiciles pour
éviter que des personnes ne soient
contraintes d'aller dans des
établissements dans lesquels ils n'ont
pas envie d'aller nous augmentons
personnel nous augmentons la qualité de
travail du personnel
nous augmentons les salaires des
personnels et nous développons des
nouvelles technologies pour venir en
aide aux personnes en perte d'autonomie
parce qu'elles sont devenues âgées et
qu'elles ont accumulé des déficits en
terme d'autonomie
c'est ce débat il s'est pas c'est pas un
problème voilà je revenais sur lui sur
l'idée sur la sémantique est utilisé ça
nous fait effectivement des débats il y
aura des solutions qui seront proposées
par des sénateurs ou des députés de
gauche
j'ai entendu le capital j'ai entendu le
profit j'ai entendu les entreprises on
est dans des choses qui sont classiques
j'ai entendu à droite on va me dire
réduisait la dépense publique ou et ses
acteurs je ne sais pas où sera l'
équilibre qui sera identifié peut-être
sera-t-il amené à évoluer en fonction de
l'évolution des gouvernements qui
viendront dans les années et les
décennies à venir peut-être c'est pas un
problème
par contre posons nous la question vite
bien et on se débat le l'idée de créer
cette cinquième manche aujourd'hui n'est
pas de couper ce débat au contraire il
est de le rendre nécessaire inévitable
et non différée abl
merci dont je disais simplement quand
monsieur mise parler de droite et de
gauche qui avec beaucoup de stéréotypes
dans son intervention
cela dit merci
s'il ya plus de questions de deux
petites interventions personnelles
vous avez parlé de madame delaunay alors
je me souviens d'une alternance d'une
altercation que j'avais eus avec elle
qui était particulièrement vive qui se
passait ici d'ailleurs j'étais à la
place de théophile et m'a même donné
était la place de monsieur van den berg
je vais poser une question sur autonomie
puisque savais pas que c'était aussi un
sujet important et elle m'avait répondu
que nous avions été nous un foutu les
sarkozystes vous avez été un faux tu
voulais sarkozyste de faire quelque
chose sur le sujet nous on va faire
quelque chose on a vu de deuxième point
important
merci pour l'ensemble des informations
que vous avez donnée ce qui ce que l'on
peut reprocher et vous avez dit que vous
souhaitiez que les parlementaires votent
ce texte en particulier sur l'autonomie
je vous réponds monsieur le ministre que
les parlementaires ne pourront pas faire
autrement que de voter ce texte sur
l'autonomie dans la mesure où ils sont
piégés par la médiatisation qui en a été
fait
la création de cette branche
tout le monde maintenant parle comme si
c'était fait et qui avait plus rien à
faire et si on veut nous intervenir
maintenant il faut qu'on accepte le
principe que l'on doit maintenant entre
architecture et l'ensemble du projet et
non plus le créé puisque les médias
l'ont fait pour nous et que là dessus on
peut pas faire marche arrière
merci en tout cas et bonne soirée à tous
voilà vous avez pu suivre l'audition du
ministre de la santé olivier véran
interrogé hier par la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat sur la
reprise de la dette sociale et sur la
création d'une branche de la sécurité
sociale relative à l'autonomie je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez retrouver tous
nos programmes et tous les articles de
la rédaction sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr je vous souhaite une
excellente journée à tous
[Musique]